go go go go go go oh man
that car wasn't there oh
is that real yeah what
hello everyone we are back with another
stuntman react we're gonna break down
some of the
coolest and perhaps not so cool stunt
scenes uh from your favorite films
let's do it all right let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
see i love this scene i love how this
was like just a horror movie
like he's in the wall yeah oh my god and
the thing is over here
trying to fight with a machete would be
like the worst experience
this is it
what i can all that can double as the
reaction
see how he's like really weaving in and
out of everybody i mean that was great
like he hits him with the machete even
though he's got the vest on so it
doesn't really hurt him
oh my oh god
so how do they do that how do they do
that how do they not just murder a man
for the sake of our entertainment right
there
i've had different theories i think it's
a dummy it looks like a dude there like
rotoden yeah yeah it does yeah i think
they're both on green screen
well if you see the uh his feet at the
end they don't completely
hit the ground see how they stop he's
like on a mat
oh you're right it's for sure green
screen them added in later
good use of vfx like when most of it's
practical you just don't see it
i i think the raid's great something
that like a lot of stunt men don't love
about it
is whenever they need beats in between
the beats
they go like this with their hands
they're like
swimming all the time
but you know something like the last
jedi could have used a bit of that
like where they're constantly like on
the move
in between the beads maybe some people
are falling down getting back up and
running in
as opposed to just posing like stuntmen
are constantly trying not to have egg on
their face
a good stunt man's just gonna fill in
the gaps with doing something
i'll just slip and fall and then stand
back up and try to be on the same timing
with a third batman movie him and
catwoman
are fighting all the other goons people
are taking reactions when they're hit by
nothing they just don't care
look at the guy in the background the
far left
like he literally just is like uh he
forgot that beat i'm just gonna
yeah no way wow
i think that they were hoping that they
would like
like put in a batarang or something like
later on
some of the problem with this is also
you can't blame it on a stunt
coordinator
nolan likes to shoot on film so there's
no playback
and if they do have playback he just
like
kind of watches the monitor and was like
that felt great
we're done
yeah that was like a foot away it's 2
a.m
yeah it's done what's the hardest hit
you've ever taken oh i do know that
uh i dove out a car you know we're
supposed to do 25 miles an hour but the
guy who's driving
he's like you know like give it what's a
smile media
no no no don't floor it okay
he's like we'll go about 20 25 but the
thing is is that when you're
you're doing some sort of car gag when
you get to the like main part you kind
of like
lean on it so you're going 28 or
something like that
we take off and the effects guy blows
the windshield right
and you know it's going to happen but
you don't realize how loud it's going to
be and how
insane it is when you're in there so i'm
in the back seat and glass starts
blowing all over my face and i'm like
subscribed and i like see the point that
i'm supposed to go and whip the door
open and dive out
and they're like that was amazing great
moving on
everybody starts packing up their stuff
i'm sitting in the corner i'd knock the
window on my cell phone
they're like eric you good and i can't
say anything because i can't breathe
[Music]
oh there it is
runs out man continue to see
savage yeah he was bounced so up on
adrenaline
oh yeah i just knew i didn't want to
screw it up like they're blowing
everything up and
like the next day every molecule in my
body
hurt that sounds about right i love the
description that everyone just packs up
like everyone just moves on
they don't check in the stunt guy he
lands in the box like all right we're
good
you know guy went all the way over in
one take yeah that was it definitely did
only in a movie directed by a stunt man
would anybody be like yeah we're gonna
use the car to
fight all the bad guys like there's no
everybody be like oh look at that dang
how great is that can you roll that back
a little bit
so this guy literally had to initiate
a slide before he hits the ramp
so that then when he launches through
the air he's going sideways
and then had to kind of gather it up as
it slides across the ground
bouncing and not hit the camera that's
that's
tracking across oh you're right look at
that oh
the camera guy's like oh go go go go go
yeah yeah there's a guy in the pursuit
vehicle is like
subscribe that's crazy i had no idea
such a technical shot
look at the guy inside bouncing up and
down
i mean we've talked a lot about tom
cruise but you know keanu reeves
he did a lot of this driving stuff
himself like once his doors come off you
get a lot of great shots of him
in there sliding the car um you know
interacting with the camera which is
i mean just action gold yeah like that
hit right
yeah i mean he's doing that do they use
kit cars for that are they destroying
that really nice car
i'm sure that they they made a kit car
out of it a kit car is
where they get something like a
lamborghini that would be way too
expensive to crash
and they remake the body out of stuff
that isn't carbon fiber
that may look like it and they're also
putting an engine in it that could be
a civic this is a 1989 honda civic
they can crash that car although it'll
still work and drive
they can crash it without the cost so
that's him right there yeah look at that
dude that's crazy
well he also slid into that position and
when it and then was able to maintain it
that was awesome that was great it's
probably all practical too i'm assuming
oh that's crazy too so they did a little
uh gag where they yank the car with the
wire
yeah and you know keanu just gets
knocked out
shot out there but he comes so close to
that back wheel even though it looks
like he's close to the back tire i think
he still probably could have pulled it
off with the limit line so that the back
wheels couldn't
possibly touch it i got you they
certainly did that with the stunt man a
couple of times and they're like look
it's gonna land here
um and keanu's tough son of a [ __ ]
so i think he he did that i feel like
the job
oh snap how do you just not break your
knees when that happens
he knows he's gonna get hit so he takes
his uh one of his feet and kind of gets
it up oh his legs never actually get
touched yeah so
he knows it's gonna happen he lifts that
one leg
and then once your weight kind of hits
it it takes your other leg up
watch he hits the brake spits him off
i feel like the style of fighting in
john wake is a bit slower
chunkier but really brutal you know more
realistic
it is see how he's yanking him with his
with his jacket
i mean that is what you would actually
do and to try to
get somebody off balance or control
their their weight or their body or
where you want them to go
although it doesn't always look as sexy
as like something in the raid where
they're
they're popping constantly john wick is
like
stunt porn basically chad stachowski
was keanu reeves stunt double throughout
the matrix oh for sure you know there's
the one scene where
agent smith blasts neo in there in the
subway fight
he goes flying back and he hits like a
subway
like ticket taking thing yeah he just
smashes through it well if you watch it
he doesn't break it
and just head just gets slammed like
this he took some gnarly hits in the
matrix
chad's been amazing with these films and
i think that you get some really great
stuff
that most directors wouldn't be able to
pull off
do you do a lot of car stuff i've
definitely done a decent amount of
driving
i know some of the guys that do some of
the fast and furious stuff and those
guys are like
true car guys you know they can
literally
slide it and stop on a dime it's
unbelievable i feel like the the fast
and furious franchise like started out
with
all good intentions and was pretty cool
they were doing something different
which stretched reality just to smidge
yeah not just like hot wheels like now
it's like a video game
yeah can you look up the the fast and
furious where they're
dragging the safe
man is that real yeah what this is real
that's why it looks really good um
what they did is i know the guys that
did this
and uh that vault that they're dragging
through the street
is a car but what i did is i took a
pickup truck
and i cut the entire middle half out of
it from
the back of the front wheels to the
front of the back wheels we took that
out
and we welded it back together so all it
has is an engine front wheels and back
wheels
and a seat and that's essentially it and
there is another guy
that is back there like looking through
like a peep hole
and he is literally like sliding the car
like like drifting this car with a bank
vault around it
are you kidding me yeah because those
wires and everything are all there
so he's you know he's keeping he's
keeping up with these guys
and driving this thing through the
streets wow
through the visual of there being a car
inside that bank just dude driving it
what a great idea like if you were like
i want to drag this this vault through
the street like would you have thought
to
have a human in there driving it and if
it was all cg
you would just it wouldn't feel the same
you just could tell
eric you've you've opened up a window
here that we otherwise wouldn't have
and i really thank you for coming out
here and sharing it all with us oh yeah
thank you for having me it's
a lot of fun to break this stuff down
with you guys now people have questions
about
the craft and they're trying to get into
this would you recommend they shoot you
a message
yeah absolutely i i try to answer
everybody believe it or not i'm not very
famous so
i i've answered a lot of questions in
the past and i'm always happy too
if you have stunts that you have
questions about like whether it's like
this thing was crazy i want you guys to
watch it or like how the heck did they
do this leave a comment down below if
you want us to react to it in the future
and we'll definitely take a look we
can't wait to read
the suggestions that you guys have